IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
"LEBOWSKI FEST F.A.Q.s."
LIVE FROM A SECRET UNDISCLOSED
LOCATION IS THE STAR AND
PRODUCER OF THE FILM "THE
GIVER," THE ONE AND ONLY, THE
DUDE, JEFF BRIDGES!
>> HEY ALL, YOU LEBOWSKI-HEADS.
LEBOWSKI FEST WAS LAST WEEKEND
IN NEW YORK BUT IT'S NEVER TOO
LATE TO START THINKING ABOUT
NEXT YEAR, MAN, YOU KNOW BECAUSE
YOU CAN STOP BY THE FEST WEB
SITE AND ACQUAINT YOURSELF WITH
THE FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS.
LIKE WHAT HAPPENS AT A LEBOWSKI
FEST?
OR HOW MANY WHITE RUSSIANS WILL
I DRINK IN ONE DAY?
OR ARE YOU ALLOWED TO ( BLEEP )
WITH THE JESUS?
I PERSONALLY WOULD NOT.
THAT'S A MISTAKE.
SO, COMEDIANS, YOUR CHALLENGE
IS TO COME UP WITH AS MANY NEW
LEBOWSKI FEST FACTS AS YOU CAN,
ALL RIGHT?
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, HAVE FUN
WITH IT.
IT'S NOT A LEAGUE GAME, MAN.
>> CHECK OUT JEFF IN "THE GIVER"
IN THEATERS NOW.
THANK YOU, JEFF BRIDGES --
@THEJEFFBRIDGES.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
YES, PETE.
>> DO YOU SERVE VIRGIN WHITE
RUSSIANS-- NOT THE DRINK?
>> POINTS. RIKI.
>> WILL TARA REID BE WORKING THE
CONCESSION STAND?
>> POINTS.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF
MOVIE- THEMED FESTIVALS.
DO THE DATES CONFLICT WITH
SCHINDLER'S FEST?
>> OH GOD.
NO POINTS.
( LAUGHTER )
KATE MICUCCI.
>> CAN YOU GET ME ANY MAN'S
TOE'S AUTOGRAPH.
POINTS. RIKI.
>> IT SMELLS LIKE DOUG BENSON IN
HERE. IS DOUG BENSON HERE?
>> HE PROBABLY IS, POINTS. KATE.
>> WHY DO MY KIDS CALL SOME
OTHER DUDE DAD?